you
[Music]
yeah so thanks for that introduction I'm
Amelia McNamara I teach statistics at
the University of st. Thomas in the
department of computer science I tweet
at Amelia MN which is a double entendre
for mcnamara and minnesota
and i'm gonna be talking about working
with categorical data in are without
losing your mind
so this talk came from a paper that I
wrote for the practical data science for
stats peerj a collection which was
organized by Jenny Brian and Hadley
Wickham and if you haven't checked out
this collection of papers yet you really
should because it's extremely useful
there are all these wonderful papers
like data organization in spreadsheets
opinionated analysis development excuse
me do you have a moment to talk about
version control and then the paper that
I worked on was called wrangling
categorical data in R so all of these
papers are fully reproducible and
they're available online on github then
they're on these sort of open-source
preprints on prj and we did a special
issue of the american statistician and
put them in there as well and and my
paper was inspired by my work as a
professor so I teach a lot of
introductory statistics classes and in
those classes I ask students to do
projects where they go out in the world
they find real data and then they
analyze it usually using you know some
modeling usually multiple regression and
this is a really useful exercise for
students because they get the experience
of working with data that's real data
that they hopefully care about but it's
very challenging for them because they
they don't always have the skills to
work with it and it's also very
challenging for me because when they
don't have the skills to work with it or
things are very complicated then I step
in and they're helping them do their
data wrangling so I always provide them
with a list of ideas where they could go
to look and find their data for their
project but they go out and make the
decision
themselves and then I help them make it
work so I had a group one year that
wanted to use data from the General
Social Survey which is housed at the
University of Chicago which is the
survey that's been going on since 1972
to ask questions about Americans about
their their life so this is a data set
that sociologists love to use and it's
it's very interesting but it's filled
with categorical variables and if you've
been working in our or working with data
you probably know about categorical data
so that's as opposed to continuous data
it's something that has kind of discrete
levels so you might think about gender
as a categorical variable you know
male-female non-binary you could think
of more categories there you can think
about you know whether you like your
coffee hot or cold that could be a
categorical variable you can think about
the colors of skittles on my front page
there's there's many types of data that
that end up being represented as
categorical and when you have survey
responses those are often like I agree I
disagree you know race is often a
categorical variable because we don't
have some continuous spectrum there so
lots of data has has categorical
variables and in our you probably know
that we represent categorical data as
factors and factors consist of a set of
values and then an ordered ordered set
of valid levels and when I started
thinking about the the paper that I was
going to write I I was thinking about
all these problems that come up when
you're doing data wrangling in real data
problems from this experience of working
with my students and so I said you know
I could write a paper on a couple
different subjects but but here's one
you know I could talk about factors and
how to recode them and so this is in May
2016 so I'm I'm fresh out of projects
and I've been thinking about how hard it
was to do the work with factor variables
specifically on this project with the
students who are working with the GSS
data
and you know on this github issue people
said uh that you know at first idea
sounds okay second one is really good so
so that's the one that I started working
on and so in in June you know I start
writing this paper and thinking about
the ways that you can work with factor
variables and do analysis in a
principled way so that you don't end up
wrecking your data and eventually this
became the paper wrangling categorical
data in our which has me and then also
Nick Horton from Amherst College he has
the best Twitter handle ask doctor stats
and so we wrote this paper and you can
go read it if it's worrying you that it
says in read not peer-reviewed you can
go read it at the American statistician
where it has been peer-reviewed and code
reviewed so it's all good so we started
off this paper by showing some of the
ways in which factors behave
unexpectedly so one of the ways is that
if you have some numeric data and you
turn it into a factor it sort of looks
the same because it has those same
values but then it has the levels
associated with it and if you convert
back to a numeric then you don't get the
numbers that you expect okay so instead
of getting back 20 20 10 40 10 I get
back to 2 1 3 1 and this is the sort of
thing that can really mess you up when
you're doing analysis with factors
because you think that you're gonna get
back the the the value but you get back
sort of the numeric level instead
there's other things like this where you
know if you create a factor variable and
give levels that don't match you're
gonna get an n/a again you don't get a
warning or a message or an error if I'd
save this into an object I just would
have seemed like it worked but I've lost
that that level of a so that there are
things like this that you learn to kind
of work around when you're working with
factor data and I think these these
frustrating issues were much more common
back
in the days of yore when we were using
read dot CSV to read in our data files
because read dot CSV has this argument
of strings as factors and that was by
default set to true so anytime you had
any character or string variable it was
getting read in as a factor and so
people were running into these
frustrating issues a lot
Roger pang has a great blog post that
strings his factors an unauthorized
biography and he talks about some of the
historical reasons why this default was
set to be true and I think the most
salient one is that it used to save
space in memory so instead of having to
save in quotes you know like high medium
low many many times as strings it would
save one two three the numerals many
times and then just keep those labels
once it turns out that even base R is no
longer doing that so it's not a it's not
a memory or storage issue anymore but
people were getting frustrated with
strings as factors not defaulting to
false this led to the strings as factors
equal hell no movement at jsm one year I
think Jenny Brian made these ribbons
that you could put on your nametag to
represent how you felt about that issue
and so when we moved into the tidy verse
kind of world where people are using
read underscore CSV that got baked into
the philosophy you shouldn't be forcing
some data format on your string or
character vectors because that might not
be what you want and you could run into
these key issues where where things can
get disconnected in a strange way so now
if you read underscore CSV you're not
going to encounter factors that much
anymore so
but the problem is you've sometimes
still need factors we can't get rid of
them altogether in particular if you're
doing modeling even just using a simple
linear model but you're including a
categorical variable a factor variable
analysis those need to be formatted as
factors so that you can choose which
level is your reference level and you
can't do that with character strings
because our we'll just pick the the
first level alphabetically
you'll also need to work with factors if
you want to reorder elements that are
maybe in your ggplot so if you have a
number of items on your plot and you
want them in some other order you need
those to be factors so that you can
reorder them properly so so we still
need to use factors and up until
reasonably recently this meant doing a
bunch of ugly bass our code so this is
an example of some ugly bass our code
that I wrote for another fully
reproducible Journal article in 2013 so
if you want to look at some like vintage
our code I recommend it this paper will
maybe come out this year so it's now six
years old and it's it's really getting
pretty classic so if you if you remember
working with factors this is the sort of
thing that you would be doing right
you'd be overwriting the levels or you'd
be reordering the levels by using square
brackets and the C function to reorder
them and so this this code actually is
probably gonna show up looking very
similar to a bad approach piece of code
that I have in a minute I did check it
and this one happens to be working
properly but I actually think that in
this paper if you go look at the code
probably I've messed up some of my
factors and my analysis is wrong as a
result so our users love to talk about
how Excel forces data to be dates for
example when you open a spreadsheet than
anything that looks at Begley like a
date becomes a date but R has similar
issues where factors can can ruin your
data in sort of a horrifying way so in
the paper that Nick Orton and I wrote we
were focusing on the GSS data and so
what we showed were some of the bad
approach
that you can use in besar so if you have
a variable about income and and you want
to order this so that it's it's in a an
appropriate order right we want far
above average to come first and then and
then above average average etc one thing
that you can do is overwrite the levels
so that's what I was doing just a minute
ago and you can watch and you can see
how this is wrecking my data so watch
like average about a thousand
observations and now average 666 okay so
because I'm overwriting
the levels outside of the factor command
I've now broken the relationship between
my levels and labels and all of my data
is now invalid and again it's not going
to give you an error or a warning
another bad approach in besar again you
could watch the average category is you
use the levels there and do it
numerically in some way so again this is
looking similar to my code that I was
showing except I think mine happened to
continue to work and so Nick and I you
know said you shouldn't be using this
kind of base our code if you're gonna
use base are you should be using a more
robust approach so you should be doing
something where you you're gonna use the
the factor command you're gonna put
levels within it and now things are
working much better if you watch for
example above average 483 that count is
gonna stay appropriate right but
something has happened to average
average actually did not come through
even though I'm using a more robust base
our approach I'm still losing my average
values because I made a typo I put a
trailing space after the word average
when I was recoding my levels okay so so
we called this a fragile up
sort of a reference to the idea of
software brittleness where if one little
thing changes then your code can break
and so we're thinking about if you had a
collaborator who sent you a new
spreadsheet and they happen to change
the the phrasing of one of the levels or
if you are a little bit fat fingering
and you hit a space then you're going to
again mess up your data but but this
approach at least is not losing the
counts for everything it's just that one
place where I made the typo okay so
we're writing this paper we're working
on it it's you know May June July of
2016 we're saying here are some bad
approaches and here are the robust you
know sort of more robust or better besar
approaches and then if you've been
following the tiny verse you probably
know the thing that happens next which
is that Hadley rights for cats so I've
been talking to Hadley Wickham about the
problems with with factor variables for
a while and my suspicion is that when he
saw me working on this paper where I
wrote out some of these very specific
issues and the ways that they probably
needed to be solved that that was just
what he needed to say now I'm actually
going to implement this package and
you'll see the inspiration there because
the dataset that comes with for cats is
also GSS so my students choice of a
final project data I think is having
far-reaching implications so he wrote
this package and it's fantastic because
it solves a huge number of the issues
that were happening when you were
working with factors in besar so if you
haven't used it before you must use it
it has it has functions like you know
recode re level reorder collapse lump
other and so it can do a lot of these
tasks that you would often want to do
with categorical data without wrecking
it and in a much more human
understandable way so with those besar
approaches
a lot of it is putting the onus on the
on the programmer right you as the
person who is doing the data analysis
have to remember what the levels are you
have to make sure that you're not
getting a space you have to kind of do
this this process where you go back and
forth between the data and your code and
you have to be very careful that you're
doing the right thing
so Brett Victor talks about how much a
cognitive load it takes to program when
you're changing things and holding the
information in your head so for cats is
helping fix a lot of that and and this
actually gave us a great opportunity for
this paper that we'd written we did have
to go back and rewrite a huge amount of
it
so thanks Hadley but I am very
interested in the variety of our
syntaxes that exist so I have this cheat
sheet which is a contributed cheat sheet
on our studio so scroll down to the
bottom and it compares doing the same
task in what I consider to be the three
main syntaxes in our the dollar sign
syntax which is kind of standard base
are the formula syntax and the tidy
verse syntax when I teach I try and stay
away from that base our syntax I was a
team formula syntax for a long time so
that's like the mosaic package and
lattice graphics and now I've been
pretty convinced to move over to the
tidy verse syntax because I think that
it removes more of that stuff you have
to hold in your head as a programmer so
what this allowed us to do the
development of for cats with our paper
is compare several different methods for
the same problem so we often show like a
compact but fragile way to do things
with base are we show a more robust but
verbose like many lines and very
repetitive coding solution and base are
and then we show the direct and robust
solution from the tidy verse so with
that data about your opinion of income
again you could watch average or below
average
you're gonna re level that factor now
everything's in the right order and the
counts are right and for cats has lots
of good defaults so you know in some
functions if you don't provide all the
factor levels it just sticks the rest of
them at the end or it'll give you good
errors and warnings
so it's fixed a lot of this stuff
another example if you did this in base
and you wanted to collapse the marital
status you could do something like this
I think this is actually working but it
really counts on you as the analyst
being able to count the indices of you
know divorced comes first and then
married and then never married no answer
and if the data changes in some way like
if your collaborator decides to move
something around it's gonna break
but the tidy vers solution using recode
is much neater and it will actually work
in a larger variety of situations so
part of my the goal of this talk is to
evangelize for for cats and the tidy
verse and get you to to use it I think
there's also something to be said about
defensive coding here so the the way
that you make sure that your examples
are working is you have to like look at
your data over and over again so this is
from an issue on that same paper this
was someone's example that had to do
with categorical data factor data
explaining the data into testing and
training data you can get different
factor levels in the two deaf datasets
and then again when you do the modeling
and the predictions it won't throw an
error but everything is gonna be wrong
so there's lots of ways that I'm working
with factors can go wrong and so one of
your methods of defense is just summary
summary summary so you saw every one of
those examples I ran a summary first
then I did something with my factors and
then I ran it again and you could use
count or something from the Tidy versus
if you wanted to this is just a little
more compact to show on the screen the
other thing that we talked about is
maybe you could get some testing worked
into your paper right so you have the
number of levels assert that the level
should be equal equal to three or test
that the level should be female and male
just that you can keep track of your of
your analysis expect equivalent doesn't
work if the levels are the right levels
but out of order so that's like on my
wish list for for future versions of the
package
and so my takeaways from this talk are
essentially that you should use for cats
that's gonna solve the vast majority of
your problems but like I said with the
testing and training data said doesn't
always solve every single problem so you
really need to be practicing defensive
coding and that probably means like your
that summary is your friend and maybe
you want to be asserting that and
testing that things in your analysis and
if you want to see more horror stories
and have a good way to explain to people
why the tidy verse is better not just
for people and their thinking but
actually for making your data work
that's the paper and thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]